e
[Música]
nacer dos veces para conseguir el éxito
y la abundancia ver hellinger dice el
éxito nos exige lo máximo
nos exige dar un sí
un asentimiento pleno y profundo
ah
el origen primigenio que nos conforma
en hacer dos veces
podría hablarnos de un camino
porque en el primer nacimiento biológico
ya nos fue dado
pero cuando completamos un segundo
nacimiento
en el primero nos viene por naturaleza
en el segundo nacimiento parece que lo
que tenemos que hacer es por
determinación propia por elección y
plena conciencia hacer un nuevo regreso
a nuestra madre ya nuestro padre ahora
simbólicos ahora desde los significados
más profundos
en hacer dos veces es un término que a
mí me ha hecho mucho sentido porque en
mi caso
fue hasta casi a los 33 años cuando nace
el tercero de nuestros hijos
que hago una reedición una revaloración
de mi historia en relación a mis padres
mi padre a mi madre cuando nace nuestro
tercer hijo hubo un aprendizaje un
hallazgo que me dije a mí mismo
cuántos 15 minutos como los que yo estoy
viviendo hablando individual mi esposa
estaba viviendo por su cuenta también
una circunstancia que vivimos con
nuestro hijo cuantos 15 minutos como
estos he vivido y he tomado de mis
padres
ahí comenzó a darse una transformación
un asentamiento una armonía de tantas
razones y juicios y valoraciones de mi
historia sobre todo en torno a mi padre
ahí comenzó
y tuve plena conciencia de un
ingrediente con el cual fue vivido a
plenitud la gratitud con la gratitud se
ríe resignifique
de manera involuntaria pero si ya más
consciente ese origen que me da soporte
ese origen que son dos mi madre y mi
padre y que atrás de ellos hay cuatro
mis cuatro abuelos y que luego hay ocho
bisabuelos
voy a ahondar un poquito en el tema de
esto de la totalidad que es la unidad sí
la dualidad a la cual hay que volver a
fusionarnos pero ahora desde el adulto
dejando la pequeñez de la infancia
para poder estar más plenos y
empoderados con esa energía creativa que
nos posibilita el éxito verdadero y que
la
abundancia entre nuestras vidas
la gratitud es la madre de todas las
virtudes dice cicerón
la gratitud es la memoria de la memoria
del alma es la flor
que enderezar el corazón y la edad
el rostro y le da la sabiduría del
rostro diría a nuestros ancestros de los
pueblos originarios
voy a resaltar lo que para mi punto de
vista es una condición ineludible para
hombres y mujeres que aspiren y que
aspiramos a estar en un continuo
encuentro con el éxito de la abundancia
en el mito de atalanta y de hipómenes
que ahora les cuento
trata de la historia de una muy hermosa
mujer y veloz
para las carreras
que puso como condición de casarse con
un hombre aquel que le ganará en la
competencia
el costo para el perdedor era su vida
varios ya habían
perdido la competencia
hipómenes con la ayuda de venus decidió
tomar el desafío de el encuentro con lo
otro que lo que lo complementaría pero
que tenía enormes retos
la ayuda de venus fueron tres manzanas
se puede ver allí en la imagen que
atalanta ya trae una manzana de oro en
la mano izquierda y con la derecha está
tomando la segunda
las manzanas de oro que fueron dadas y
veamos que fueron dadas por la energía
femenina
como armas como recursos para qué
hipómenes pudiera ganar la competencia
así fue mientras se distraía o se
detenía atalanta
y pulmones puedo avanzar y ganar la
competencia llegaron al final feliz
pudieron ser pareja consumar su relación
de pareja pero hipómenes olvidó algo
fundamental agradecer
la ayuda de la diosa venus venus que
había posibilitado su victoria
como consecuencia al no dar la gratitud
fueron los dos convertidos en dos leones
que por la eternidad estarían jalando la
carreta de cibeles
en eso nos podemos convertir podemos ser
niños de 50 o de 60 años si no hemos
regresado a nacer dos veces desde los
significados de gratitud sobre todo por
haber recibido lo más valioso en este
plano terrenal que es la vida y la vida
solamente nos viene de dos nunca viene
solo de uno por eso es renacer dos veces
renacer con los significados
ahora ya desde el adulto con la madre y
también renacer desde nuevos indicados
ahora con el padre
sin embargo complemento el mito para que
pueda realizarse sobre todo para los
hombres este logro la madre es
fundamental así como y pomán es recibe
la ayuda a través de las tres manzanas
de oros
la madre es la que da la buena dirección
y el permiso y el consentimiento porque
tiene potestad de vida y de muerte sobre
el hijo
qué quiere decir esto que si la madre no
permite que el hijo vaya al padre se
queda sin completar el segundo
nacimiento y si en el segundo nacimiento
se queda partido y dividido
las imágenes que después revisaré
rápidamente
creo desde el punto vista que hablan de
esta actualidad que hay que integrar si
siempre hay que integrar dos no solo uno
para poder recuperar ahora la totalidad
como adulto porque desde la parte de las
neurociencias estamos conformados por
una parte de energía perdón ante mente
femenina con intuición sí con amor con
afecto y una parte masculina que es más
racional que es más de ir al mundo a la
conquista
entonces renacer dos veces es algo que
les invito a que cada quien se plantee
si le hace sentido en mi caso
podría decir que fue casi hasta los 33
años que comencé un renacer que la vida
a través de circunstancias me dio la
oportunidad de disolver de desprender de
soltar juicios
qué
daban razón a historias y a discursos
pero que no me empodera van sí porque
solamente reeditando la historia esto es
muy muy este abordado en los campos de
la psicología en el tema de la misma
filosofía del camino del héroe solamente
reeditando solamente siendo otros sí
ya dejando esa pequeñez infantil del
amor ciego del amor que que tiene el
deseo de hacer cosas grandes de salvar
pero sobre todo de ayudar solamente que
toma lugares que no le corresponden
entonces
las imágenes de la dualidad las dos
energías masculina y femenina es un gran
viaje es un gran
recorrido el que hay que hacer para que
dos se encuentren en un instante se hace
uno ese uno se divide en dos
en esta
pintura de van gogh podemos ver esos dos
que son padre y madre que hay un tercero
que es el que lo relaciona es esa nueva
unidad que se conforma de ellos dos pero
que ya es otro
esta pintura de rembrandt habla o
podemos interpretar de una un hombre
seguramente más un hombre que una mujer
aproximadamente unos 20 años pero que
está en una actitud de total rendición y
a sumisión y de humildad para volver
está como tocando el vientre del padre
para volver a renacer desde los símbolos
y significados de haber de ahora tomar
con gratitud habiendo hecho una
conversión un regreso porque si
recordamos la parábola del regreso del
hijo pródigo primero le dice dame la
herencia ya no quiero más de ti y quiero
irme al mundo allá vive las condiciones
que le hacen tocar plena conciencia de
cuál es el origen que lo puede empoderar
y regresa empequeñecido y humilde y con
un corazón dócil y con una actitud de
rendición y de honra al padre al padre
que simbólicamente dicen los expertos
está plasmado en
metáfora en madrid' padre si por los
símbolos que tiene de rasgos que está
plantando y pintando rembrandt
esta esta geometría que para mí es una
[Aplausos]
una poesía de los símbolos de los
significados que hablan de la dualidad
para los que ya la han tenido porque a
conocerla tiene las dos partes que se
están uniendo las dos serpientes que en
sentido contrario están conformando una
unidad solamente
regresando por el camino de fundirnos
desde el adulto ahora desde el adulto
luminoso fundiendo nos con un
asentimiento pleno y total a todo lo que
es y como es sin agregar ni quitar nada
a nuestro padre a nuestra madre a
nuestra cultura de los pueblos
originarios a la nueva cultura del viejo
mundo europeo solamente así desde mi
punto de vista podemos empoderarnos para
ir hacia el éxito y hacia la abundancia
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]